غير بعيد عن لندن في مقاطعه هارت حقل صغير
لانتاج قمح من نوع خاص يشرف عليه مركز رضم
ستاد واحد من اقدم مؤسسات البحوث الزراعيه
في اوروبا هذا القمح نتاج تجربه جديده
اجراها علماء النبات والمحاصيل
لمعرفه ما اذا كان بامكانهم تعديل الجين
الذي ينتج مركبا يسمى اسبرا جي وهو حمض
اميني طبيعي
ما نحاول القيام به هو تقليل كميه
الاسبراجين في حبوب القمح وهذا يعني انه
ستكون هناك كميه اقل من ماده الاكريلاميد
المتكونه في الخبز واقل عند تحميصه يوجد
اسباراجين بشكل طبيعي في النباتات وهو
ضروري لصحتها وينظم تخزين النيتروجين ولكن
عندما يحول القمح الطحين ويخبز يتحول
الاسبراجيل الى مركب اخر يسمى الاكريليمي
وهو ماده مسرطنه حسب ما يقول العلماء
ما نتحدث عنه فيما يتعلق بالمخاطر طويله
المدى في الطعام مرتبط اكثر باشياء مثل
مخاطر الاصابه بالسرطان وذلك لان ماده
الاكريلاميد في طعامنا تمر بعمليه في
الجسم وتتحول الى ماده كيميائيه اخرى
تتفاعل بدورها مع حمضنا النووي
اشعل علماء من خلال تعديل القمح جينيا الى
جعل الخبز اقل عرضه لتسبب بالسرطان بعد
تحميصه وفي تجارب انتاج قمح معدل وراثيا
يستخدمون التكنولوجيا المعروفه باسم
لاجراء تغييرات دقيقه على الحمض النووي في
انسجه حبه القمح هنا يزال جزء صغير من
الانسجه من الحبوب وتغذى في صفيحه بيتري
تزيل هذه العمليه الصفات الجينيه من الحمض
النووي لكنها مختلفه تماما عن الاطعمه
المعدله وراثيا
ربما يفكر المستهلكون ومعظم الناس في ان
هذه النباتات تحوي جينا اضافيا من نوع
مختلف هذه نباتات معدله ليس فيها جينات من
انواع اخرى لا جينات اضافيه على الاطلاق
اقتصرت الدراسات التي تربط ماده
الاكريلامي بعواقب سلبيه محدده مثل
السرطان على التجارب على الحيوانات حتى
الان لهذا السبب يقول العلماء انه بين
الصعب استخلاصه اي استنتاجات لكنهم
يعتقدون ان الحد من المخاطر ربما يكون
شيئا جيدا
سيقيم القمح الذي ينمو في هذا الحقل بعد
حصاده في اكتوبر لمعرفه ما اذا كان حساب
البيدر مطابقا لحساب الحقل